revenir sur cette soirée qui a fait
énormément parler et c'est vrai que
voilà il ya eu on a vu un don clos
mouvement de la majorité présidentielle
en somme on remporte 245 sièges et donc
majoritaires à l'assemblée mais non plus
la majorité absolue puisqu'il fallait
289 sièges moi j'ai rien compris à
l'histoire on m'a tout raconté la nuque
ps a obtenu 131 sièges dont raquel
garrido
la france a soumises en elle même donc
72 72 de france a soumises c'est ce
qu'il faut savoir et le rassemblement
national a remporté 89 sièges c'est le
record absolu pour eux et c'est
peut-être le grand gagnant de cette
élection marine le pen a d'ailleurs bien
dit que c'étaient les grands gagnants
voilà c'était nadal à roland garros
je vais vous virer un mais deux
des quatre salles déjà commencé les mecs
ont bien failli l'envoyer taux moyen
pour un centre à l'assemblée avec un
très puissant groupe de députés
nous sommes le premier parti
d'opposition
devant la france est soumise et par
conséquent nous allons pouvoir devrait
comme un groupe d'opposition comme je
l'avais
solliciter des français de plein pouvoir
avec l'intégralité des moyens qui sont
accordées par les reconstitutions à un
groupe d'opposition qui est le premier
de l'assemblée
alors voilà et il y aller mais jean luc
mélenchon aussi souhaite absolument que
la nuque ps reste en un seul groupe
nous devons
être et rester une alternative unis
autrement dit la nuit devrait se
constituer comme un seul groupe au
parlement de manière à ce que sans
aucune discussion possible il soit
établi qui
mène l'opposition dans le pays et que
dès lors nous soyons prêts à tout moment
y compris s'il ya de nouvelles élections
a présenté la candidature de l'anip
oui non c'est bon merci c'est la
révélation va avoir maintenant une
nouvelle figure de l'assemblée c'est la
révélation de ces législatives investi
par l'ats denis pesce rachel kéké
militants cgt devient la première femme
de chambre a accédé à la fonction de
député en france regardez la réaction de
celle qui vote la voix et sans voir
victoire est historique
je suis tellement ému de cette belle
campagne examiner et je savais qu'en
face de moi j'avais le ministre des
sports oksana mais comme je dis je
n'avais pas peur parce que j'avais froid
mois l'ensemble el nacional celle là où
le peuple s'exprime dans celles où tu
sonnes les représentants du peuple à
l'assemblée nationale je suis très
content calibre est très content que
rachel cac et gagné parce que oksana là
c'est une banane flambée
ministre a été nulle elle est députée et
l'insee rien on hamm est de retour et
c'est quoi comme sport d'ailleurs c'est
là maracineanu nageuse un certain flou
allez merci ça comme ça ce sera fait le
chroniqueur de tpm paix était il ya eu
raquel garrido rail dure et louis boyard
est un avatar dont le maïs gm plus
jeunes et puis la france où il avait
tout donné dans la com regarder sa
parodie de fort boyard
[Musique]
vous avez des bons plans
c'est alors il ya également aymeric
caron qui a été élu vous savez figure de
la télévision qui fait son entrée à
l'assemblée aymeric caron est élu dans
la dix huitième circonscription de paris
sous l'étiquette nubes raquel garrido
également regarder à l'annoncé elle-même
sa victoire garde
notre résultat je peux vous annoncer que
j'ai gagné j'ai battu jean christophe
lagarde le président de l'udps et y est
d'abord je voudrais dire un grand merci
aux habitants de drancy du bourget et de
bobigny qui ce soir vraiment font un
geste extraordinaire de liberté de
liberté on va pouvoir respirer je suis
très heureux et très fier vous savez moi
je suis arrivé en france à l'âge de 14
ans je suis devenue française à 25 ans à
35 ans j'ai repris mes études comme et
de petites lt sortie des couches pour
devenir avocate et pour moi entrer à
l'assemblée nationale ce soir c'est une
très grande fierté voilà raquel garrido
là j'ai eu hier d'ailleurs ça y est pas
encore très tard à la suite rétorqué m
elle avait gagné et voilà il ya alors il
ya julien houdu l'oci qui a été à
nouveau député karl olive voilà qui
pourrait un nombre qui pourrait faire
parler à l'assemblée karl olive dont il
ya beaucoup de gens diraient qu'on voit
beaucoup sur les plateaux télé qui ont
été élus alors celle qu'on voit souvent
sur les plateaux télé qui nous fait
toujours un match ou si rachida dati et
comme d'habitude hier elle s'est fait
plaisir c'est le rachida dati chaud
moi je vois comment madame bord n'était
lui pas franchement c'est un échec aussi
point le premier ministre de gauche le
teich termine car oui oui mais c'est les
cirysiens journal accapare donc
c'est pas pareil même groupe public jean
regarder on peut le lire on peut le dire
vous n'êtes pas de décodeur de monsieur
copé elle a regardé j'espère vraiment
décodeur nouvelle justin propos et mais
justement si cette fois c'est par
exemple effet je file propos ou des
rapports non vers l'homme dit vous fait
désagréable à main qui est d'avoir un
fils est d'avoir fait un tabac qui
serait
vous serez la béquille d'emmanuel
maintenant emmanuel quand il viendra
vous voir entendre et qui s'il vous
plaît cette la benelli mais comme je
n'ai pas une tête de béquilles mais pas
vous personnellement vous le savez en
plus ça y'est bilan désastreux en tine
aujourd'hui elle vous a envoyé depuis
très longtemps
rachida dati alors qu'on la préfère
faire des plateaux beaucoup moi regarder
mais voilà c'est son droit mais on aime
bien quand même
un bel vous aime beaucoup je suis moi
j'ai eu c'est vrai un moment il faut il
faut des preuves vous savez
le haricot c'est sûr quand ça monte à la
tête ah j'ai jamais très bon il y en a
qu'un qui a passé une belle soirée une
merde le pot c'est gabriel attali t sur
les plateaux après la petite déception
de son parti aux élections il aurait
peut-être dû rester chez lui à chaque
fois qu ils étaient là ils ont
regardé
bonsoir gabriela talent bonsoir c'est
une défaite une lourde une très lourde
défaite pour la république en marche et
aujourd'hui qui a changé de nom qui
s'appelle ensemble comment expliquer ce
vote sanction richard ferrand christophe
castaner sont des grandes figures de la
république en marge puisque et qu'est ce
que vous payez ce soir j'allais bien
quand même le premier ministre un peu le
chef de la majorité celle qui fait un
peu campagne qui convient à votre compte
en vous confiant si elle est élue
franchement vous voyez les résultats
vous vous prenez une tôle bah c'est
triste mais on passe tous par là n'était
pas le résultat qu'on essaierait
vous n'allez pas là plaisir que
[Musique]
il y en a d'autres pour qui ce n'était
pas leur soit rien ce sont les ministres
qui se présentaient qui n'ont pas été
élus les gars où régneront voilà ils ont
créé qui fait leur force que quelques
semaines il aurait été ministre et
ministre que quelques semaines aient pu
terminer parce que tous ceux qui n'ont
pas élu doivent démissionner à prouver
se présente moi si j'avais eu loris sur
rue et libre je me présente pas parce
que le président avait dit qu'il fallait
qu'ils aillent dans la bataille sans fin
la bataille ils ont quel à faire chez
eux regardent et
brigitte bourguignon ministre de la
santé et de la prévention j'ai déjà
toutes ces rencontres prévues dans mon
agenda vous l'imaginez bien je vous
allez sur le terrain aussi à leur
rencontre je veux les écouter gilles
bourguignon vous rappelle nature de la
santé qui est battu madame justine bénin
chargé de la mer je dois dire que c'est
une fierté au moins d'être en charge du
ministère de la mer ce à travers des a
chargé de la mer justine bénin a été
vaincu madame amélie de montchalin
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires couverts
est un ministre qui va créer les
conditions d'un ministre de la
transition écologique à m'évite de
montchanin qui serait battue est plutôt
largement
voilà la nouvelle
c'est vrai qu'elle a alors avant de
connaître les résultats des élections
jean luc mélenchon a fait parler de lui
en prévenant que dès lundi donc ce matin
il attendrait le coup de fil du
président pour lui demander d'être
premier ministre regarde serait ou lundi
matin eh bien je serai chez moi vous
voulez vous que je sois j'attendrai le
coup de téléphone du président de la
république pour moi demandé de former le
gouvernement
alors nos équipes sachez ont suivi le
standard de jean luc mélenchon ont toute
la matinée toute la journée pour
vérifier les appels qu'il a reçus
regarde
de mélenchon
[Musique]
charlie chan prénom de mélangeront
bonjour oui bonjour monsieur mélenchon
marie line de l'organisme transformation
savez vous que de l'argent d'or sur
notre camp de formation et que grâce à
nous vous pouvez devenir aussi risque
cyril hanouna quoi je suis klich alors
service après-vente de mélenchon bonjour
jean luc et commencera à mon chéri et et
dj j'ai appris qu'elle proposait écoute
bien est ce que tu voudrais être le
premier ministre premier ministre
presque au shérif et je te propose
d'être le premier politique à intégrer
le 6 à 7 avec casta est il que dur ça va
être une dar k
marij 6-3 1-6 5-7 service après-vente de
mélenchon bonjour monsieur mélenchon à
monsieur le président alors hier tu as
vu de quoi mon tu
es gimont qui est risible mesure j'ai
dit mon cul
de mélenchon
il ya une image qui ressort pour qu'ils
reçoivent beaucoup depuis hier et qui
fait polémique c'est quelque chose de
terrible
jean luc mélenchon vous avez de merde
selon l'udc aurait fait une castaldi
tout le monde se pose la question est ce
que jean luc mélenchon à ips alors pour
certains c'est juste quelqu'un en
plateau qui approuve ce qu'il dit mais
d'autres sont formels il appétit vous
allez vous faire votre idée moi je sais
ce que j'en pense en tant que
spécialiste du pays depuis quatre à six
simplement le fait qu'on ait quelque
chose comme 2 ou 3 points de croissance
faisait qu'on trouvait plus d'ouvriers
pour aller sur les chantiers de saint
nazaire où il ya lorsqu'on appelle une
forme c'est à dire un endroit où on met
les m'installe des bateaux à
l'endroit où on met les installe des
bateaux à
cette question restera longtemps sans
réponse
mais la réponse n'hésitez pas à nous
dire hier soir sur les plateaux télé
aussi on a eu droit à un gros clash
entre alexis corbière et le ministre de
la famille dupont moretti regret c'est
emmanuel macron qui a été réélu et
plutôt brillamment ne vous en déplaise
maintenant dans madame le pen maintenant
contre vous aussi puisque vous êtes
arrivés troisièmes jeux vous êtes encore
arrogant ce soit mais ça ne les
attendait pardon je retrouve le
dupond-moretti que j'ai vu pendant des
années vous êtes encore à rouen madame
je vous adore plateforme id alexis
carmes y arriver quand une seconde bravo
lyrics born british explique non mais
les invectives non j'ai pas les
invectives c'est vous me parlez pas sur
ce ton s'il vous plaît alexis corbière
j'ai dit que c'était un résultat
décevant mais je vais corbières une
défaite choisissez les mots que vous
voulez du moment que vous ne choisissez
pas les mots de l'invectivé oui voilà
bon alors voilà mois après et puis celle
à nu chez danube est son nom après avoir
été élus ou réélus parmi eux il ya eu go
bernard lice issaoui pourtant les
députés insoumis se voyait plutôt
ministre de l'intérieur le gars était
même lancer dans le rap game
par ordre alphabétique ugo bernalicis de
la france insoumise et la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale bonjour
burgaud à beauvau q2 à bonvaux me contre
la police comme hugo abogo darmanin à
chaud hulot à beauvau mélenchon à
matignon et hugo à beauvau ranger
derrière jlm esso la gauche et les
copains de la nuit baisse tous les
marchands me reconnaissent quand je me
paval turrel m cité de l'ill city tu
peux me croiser dans le city 2 tacite et
pernal ici pas sarkozy contre la droite
faut résister hugo à beauvau tudeau un
bon vaut légalise le cannabis comme il
est
possible pour l'instant il va être
député ouais ça sera ça se passera très
bien